we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p call anytime here's a voicemail
a good morning Dave Louis as making
Connecticut a member and Watson so for a
while to sawyer park with Gordon
Klingenschmitt I'm curious if a
Christian goes into a gay bakery in
Colorado will the gay Baker be able to
tell them no they're not going to make a
cake with a cross on it because of the
anti-gay attitude that sometimes follow
that yeah just curious it works both
ways thank you the reward s I've said it
before I'll say it again it absolutely
should work both ways but good luck
convincing the Christians of that here's
the thing right because gay isn't a
religion and christianity is so there's
uh there's protection of religion not so
much protection of individuals well you
just need to have a religion that you
are part of that is against anti-gay
beliefs and then you can say it's my
religion that I don't deal with people
who are anti-gay maybe gay should be a
religion and then have themselves
awarded all of these great protections
the double standard is stunning as the
caller is pointing out great bonus show
today we will talk about a Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro telling women
not to blow dry their hair to save
electricity everything's fine though no
problem with the electricity supply
there Americans go to Cuba and Cuba runs
out of beer and more sign up for today's
bonus show at david pakman.com slash
membership and for the next week you can
get a thirty-three percent discount off
of your membership and what the heck
i'll throw in a free t-shirt for you but
you must sign up at david pakman.com
slash spring 16